hi guys I'm Erik Bosse and Avengers
infinity war released another advance
look at a scene ahead of the movie's
release this week with Bruce Banner Tony
Stark's Stephen strange and Wong with a
few interesting tidbits in there they're
not huge spoilers but yeah tidbits
limitless
I know I know where's so close to the
premiere to tip it or not to tidbit mm
that's great you know you wanna and
obligatory spoiler warning even though
we're not gonna ruin anything I just you
know I want to cover you because I care
okay let's watch the first part of this
scene tell me who's name again
Thanos he's a play Tony he invades
planets he takes what he wants he wipes
out half the population he said Loki the
attack on New York that's him
okay so Bruce Banner is briefing Tony
Stark on Thanos his whole threat level
and his connection to past MCU events as
the villain behind Loki's attack in the
first Avengers movie there in the
sanctum sanctorum with Doctor Strange
and Wong and if you look behind Banner
you could see the stairs are all broken
up and splintered so this is probably
taking place after a banner crash lands
in the sanctum banners way more
terrified here than we've ever seen him
whatever went down between his return
New York and thanasis ships arrival in
the post-credits scene Thor Ragnarok the
sequence which I believe we've seen in a
few whirring shots and the other
trailers actually go check out our
breakdown videos on those all that must
have scared the crap out of banner for
him to be speaking in this tone also
notice the little detail a banner
snapping his fingers the moment he says
wipes out half the planet this of course
is a little call back to Thanos's famous
threat which is pulled from the Infinity
Gauntlet comics when he does just that
and Stark responds with a grim this is
it for Stark the opening of the cosmic
portal through which Loki's Chitauri
army poured in has been the single most
traumatic event on his whole mental
state it causes anxiety attacks in Iron
Man 3 it motivated his foolish creation
of Ultron in Avengers 2 and it arguably
led to his whole need to rein in Earth's
heroes from scattered rogue agents into
a unified government body and Civil War
this fear of what else is out there has
been driving him throughout all these
movies and now that fear has been
realized
Jack Scribus now before I get to the
second half of the clip thank you to
honey for sponsoring today's video
is a free browser extension that over
nine million people are using every day
to save money while they shop online
honey works on Chrome Safari and Firefox
and installing it is super simple it
only takes two clicks just go to join
honeycomb slash new rockstars to get
started once that's finished any time
you had to check out in an online store
honey will automatically apply the best
coupon code it can find to give you the
biggest discount check it out I just use
honey when I bought a couple pizzas from
Papa John's to get me through rewatching
all the MCU movies it was a freaking
marathon and I needed sustenance don't
judge him look honey save me $8 68 since
I'm so sweet there really isn't any
reason not to add honey to your browser
it's free and it takes just two clicks
to install and it will save you money
and if you really want to support her
channel go to join honey calm slash new
rock stars or click on the link in the
description below okay let's check out
the second half of this clip what's her
timeline no telling he has the power and
space stones that already makes him the
strongest creature in the whole universe
if he gets his hands on all six stars
Tony he could destroy life on a scale
hitherto undreamt on did you seriously
just say hither to hundred of I'm
seriously leaning on the cauldron of the
cosmos never that I'm going to allow
that if there are stains all six why
don't we just stick this one down a
garbage disposal no can do we swore an
oath to protect the time stone with our
lives
and I swore off dairy then managers
named a flavor after me so start craving
hazelnuts not bin chalky
okay after some playful posturing
between stark and strange Tony proposes
destroying the time stone in Strange's I
have a komodo an idea they get shot down
because the Sorcerer's took a vow to
protect the time stone with their lives
it's also probably not even possible to
destroy an infinity stone they predate
everything they were reportedly used as
building blocks to assemble the universe
itself they're not like the ring from
Lord of the Rings that can just be
tossed into the fires of Mount Doom from
whence it came or as start suggests into
a garbage disposal from I like the
details Stark turning away to stretch
almost as if he's hiding his scared
expression from the others under the
guise of limbering up for a fight and in
case we were wondering the cauldron of
the cosmos is indeed one of dr.
Strange's mystical artifacts from the
Marvel Comics in the Marvel team of
issue 112 strange helps spider-man
recover from a poisonous battle with the
serpent men and he uses the flames from
the cauldron of the cosmos to look
backward in time 20,000 years to an
ancient human civilization for an
antidote
perhaps strange will use this cauldron
to look backward in time maybe for a way
to defeat Thanos but more likely it
could just be meant as a little nod to
the comics the way many of the other
artifacts and Doctor Strange movie
worked stark mentions that he swore off
dairy until Ben and Jerry's named an ice
cream flavor after him stark raving
hazelnuts and even though it wouldn't
surprise me at all to see Ben and
Jerry's cash in on this as of right now
stark raving hazelnuts is not currently
a real-life flavor it Ben injuries so
you know don't show up in any of those
stores and flip out like you did for
Rick and Morty's schedule on sauce guys
people who scoop ice cream haven't
enough to stress out about like
shrinking down in the ant-man middle I
know that was Baskin Robbins dumping a
Jerry shut up but a question for you
guys what do you think is the smartest
way to contain the Infinity stones keep
them together in one guarded location or
scattered em across the universe
drop them between your car seat and the
door no one will ever find them that way
comment down below with your thoughts or
tweet me directly I da boss and
following new rock stars on Twitter for
updates on our videos like and share
this video and subscribe to the arc
stars for all of our infinity war deep
dives guys we're in the middle of
infinity week be sure to check out all
of our other Avengers related stuff that
we're doing it's all great it's all
worth watching but thank you for
watching this